ah on va revenir sur cette affaire qui
avait fait énormément réagir il y a
quelques semaines cette influenceuse
Warda en noir en noir qui avait diffusé
une vidéo dans laquelle elle tournait en
dérison l'information du bébé israélien
mort dans un four lors de l'attaque
terroriste du 7 octobre et bien son
procès s'est tenu cette semaine euh et
10 mois de prison avec surc ont été
requis contre elle par le procureur dans
un instant on va voir l'avocat de cette
jeune femme hein donc c'est une exclu
importante qui se satisfait plutôt de
cette réquisition euh qui sera avec nous
et euh c'est vrai que voilà ils sont
plutôt satisfaits de de de l'issue du du
procès regardez cette
vidéo moi il y a une chose qui me qui me
ture le pine je je je je vais je vais je
vais vous donner le fond de ma pensée
sans filtre à chaque fois que je tombe
sur l'histoire du bébé qui a été mis
dans le four je me pose la question de
s'ils ont mis du sel du poivre s'ils ont
mis du thin ils l'ont fait revenir à
quoi et et ça a été quoi
l'accompagnement vous posez pas la
question vous je sais pas accompagnement
avec ce gigot de bébé nétait contutre
qu'une assiette de frit avec une sauce
ketchup et
mayonnaise et on l'a mariné avec du sel
du thint et avec une sauce barbecue et
du
paprik pas mal moi je trouve que c'est
un un menu plutôt pas mal alors
êtes-vous choqué ce mec qui mettent oui
pensent que c'est pas assez he ceux qui
mettent non pensent que c'était c'était
ce qu'il fallait avoir donc 10 mois de
prison avec surcis merci Maître Malaoui
d'être avec nous C l'avocat de cette
jeune fille bah pour vous c'est plutôt
une victoire non cette décision une
victoire non moi je ce que je dis c'est
que dans le cas de cette audience il y a
eu deux phases la première nous avons
soulevé un certain nombre d'arguments de
procédure notamment une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité qui
visait à contester le fait qu'une
personne pour une infraction en droit de
la presse puisse être envoyée en
compartion immédiate il a eu ensuite
l'audience au fond je pense que tout le
monde a pu s'exprimer tant les partis
civiles que nous autres les deux avocats
de la défense et puis nous avons écouté
les réquisitions nous y avons répondu et
puis nous sommes en attente du délibérer
alors Gill ver vous trouvez-vous que
cette 10 mois de prison avec surcis ça
vous choque pas c'est assez trve je
trouve que c'est un moindre mal vu
l'audience qui a été catastrophique et
je trouve que c'est un moindre mal et si
jamais elle est condamnée infin à ça
c'est déjà un miracle parce que je
trouve que les avocats ont perverti
l'audience je vous le dis les yeux dans
les yeux vous avez été bon mais ils ont
perverti l'audience c'est-à-dire que
elle a réussi à passer pour une F lambda
je suis pas influenceux je suis pas
mannequin j'ai rien fait finalement bon
j'ai pas vraiment dit que le Hamas c'est
un mouvement terroriste et cetera donc
ils ont réussi un peu à ridiculiser le
propos moi j'ai été choqué par votre
stratégie c'est une très bonne stratégie
d'avocat mais je trouve que c'est pas
moral je tenais à vous le dire alors je
j'écoute si vous parlez de perversion
juridique peut-être c'est ce que nous
avons fait c'est faire notre travail
c'est-à-dire que il y a des infractions
qui aujourd'hui sont légiférées et nous
avons une norme suprême en France qui
s'appelle le Conseil constitutionnel et
lorsque nous autres avocats parce que
nous ne nous ne faisons pas de morale
nous faisons du droit et bien si cela
irrite certaines personnes et que ça
vous gêne et que ça vous chagrine que
nous fassions du droit et développons
les arguments je veux bien l'entendre
mais nous en réalité nous raisonnons
dans deux partitions différentes vous
êtes sur le terrain de la morale et vous
avez le droit je suis sur le terrain du
droit quand juste Daniel alors moi je
trouve que c'est pas assez il fallait
plus et je pense que cette personne n'a
même pas compris le enfin c'est même pas
qu'elle a pas compris maiselle elle est
pas consciente de ce qu'elle a fait sauf
que quand même est-ce que vous pouvez me
confirme que la petite abeille parce que
moi j'étais étonné il vous sais il y a
une petite abeille sur la la vidéo avec
Israël on t'aime et quelqu'un m'a
expliqué qu'en fait c'était pour déjouer
l'algorithme pour que le message passe
quand même est-ce que c'est vrai parce
que pour moi ça c'est une circonstance
atténuante et aggravante pardon et donc
de toute façon dis magistrat du siège
c'est pas moi à qualifier ce que sont
les circonstances aggravantes ou pas ce
que je vous dis par contre quand vous
dit dit c'est pas asseé elle est pas
encore condamnée non non mais le je par
réinstant trve ce sont des réquisitions
du ministère public il y aura un
délibéré le 6 en fonction de du choix au
niveau de la peine des magistrats vous
pourrez juger oui ou non si c'est
quelque chose qui vous convient ou si
vous estimez comme certains ont pu le
dire qu'elle méritait les affres de la
détention mais enfin rien que ça ça veut
dire que c'est pas une blague maladroite
et je crois aussi qu'elle a qu'elle a
enfin y a par exemple dans les partis
civiles la maman d'une d'une jeune fille
qui a été bah voilà dont le corps a été
brûlé pendant les l'attaque du 7 octobre
qui se constitu parti civile qui demande
un euro symbolique je crois et je crois
que cette personne a refusé de de
répondre au parti civil alors pourquoi
enfin voilà moi je trouve que déjà
l'attitude AG grave ce qu'elle a ce
qu'elle a pu faire et ce ce côté
prémédité où on va éviter l'algorithme
pour que le message passe beau bien
c'est pas une blague maladroite comme on
a voulu faire alors je je me permets de
vous rappeler quand même qu'elle est pas
jugée pour les attaques terroristes du 7
octobre ne pas répondre à à une femme
qui a été choquée par son message déjà
c'est choquant en soi simplement ça une
salle d'audience il y a certaines règles
il y a un code de procédure pénale en
France encore alors peut-être que
certains discuteent hein le fait que
certains aent des droits il y a même des
gens qui pensent qu'en garde à vue il
faudrait peut-être pas d'avocat et que
peut-être en réalité les jugements
devraient être des jugements à
l'emporte-pièce ce que je vous dis
madame vous êtes en train de m'indiquer
certaines choses avec l'algorithme et
cetera moi ce que je vous dis en réalité
c'est qu'il y a eu une audience tout le
monde a pu s'exprimer qu'il y a des
règles extrêmement précises par note de
code de procédure pénal qui permettent à
des gens de se constituer partie civile
et si vous ne rentrez pas dans les
critères du code de procédure pénale
vous n'êtes pas constitué parti civile
c'est aussi simple que ça il n'y a
aucune dérogation il n'y a pas de
mansuétude il y a rien du tout il y a
juste le respect scrupuleuse de la règle
de droit oui moi le seul fait que que
que que vous maître soyez content des
réquisitions ça prouve que vous
attendiez peut-être à plus et que si
vous attendiez à plus et qu'elle
mériteit plus et donc je suis choqué
qu'elle ait pas eu plus et je suis
surtout choqué le fait que qui a peur
d'un surcis personne ça fait peur
personne ça n'a pas valeur d'exemple
pour pour avoir pas pas
avir ça pas valeur d'exemple un surc on
sait c'est quelque chose qui peressus de
la
tête ce qui me surprend moi c'est que
vous sentiez que je matérialise une joie
là où je la donne pas vous me sentez
spécialement joyeux non mais vous étiez
plôt content des réquisitions mais non à
quel moment est-ce que vous avez
vu du tout j'ai dit que j'ai fait valoir
des arguments de droit je vois pas où
est-ce que je suis en d'exciper de vous
parlez vous parlez de façon totalement
technique monsieur monsieur vous parlez
de façon totalement technique alors
qu'en fait là il y a l'émotionnel qui
rentre en compte parce que le sujet est
particulièrement touchant et qu'estce
qui se passe en ce moment c'est très
compliqué moi je me dis en fait quel
exemple on donne c'estàdire que
maintenant en fait on va pouvoir
continuer à on va se dire toute façon il
va rien m'arriver je vais continuer à
dire ce que je veux sur internet il
m'arrivera strictement rien de concret
et c'est ça le message qu'on est en
train de faire passer et les gens ne
peuvent pas l'accepter vous comprenez ça
mais ce que je comprend c'est qu'il y a
un droit en France Monsieur si
vous vous
comprenez par ma vous faites GRI à un
avocat de faire du droit il faut
peut-être vous poser quelques questions
voyez si vous faites GRI à un avocat de
faire du droit moi je suis pas avocat
moi je vous parle comme ça ave jeis
avocat je viens avoc quand quelqu vous
parle avec le cœur vous pouvez pas
toujours lui répondre comme un
ordinateur je viens en tant qu'avocat je
suis pas là en tant que militant
monsieur donc si vous pensez inviter un
philosophe vous êtes trompé d'inviter
bah il y a un peu de philosophie dans le
métier d'avocat aussi si vous voulez
mais en tout cas moi je suis là pour
défendre les gens ne vous en déplaise
Raymon moi je pense que le message
envoyé c'est comme comme on dit les
camarades le message envoyé il est
catastrophique parce que ça veut dire
que tu peux refaire une vidéo comme ça
quel que soit le bébé on dit un bébé
pastinen ou un autre bébé peu importe tu
fais pas tu dis pas d'un bébé tuit dans
un four et cetera et cetera je trouve
que le message est catastrophique et je
me pose des questions souvent sur les
peines encues parfois tu t'embrouilles
avec un chocolatier tu vas en prison et
là sur des trucs comme ça on dit bah
c'est pas grave tu tu tu fais ça tu
auras que 10 mois 10 mois de prison
continites encore des vidéos où vous
vous moquez d'un bébé avec en plus son
fils parce qu' a son fils qui je sais
pas un enfant qui est là qui se moque
aussi on met ça pour déjouer aussi
l'algorithme moi j'aurais peut-être 10
mois en prison 10 mois avec surcil
peut-être pas mais peut-être peut-être
une autre sanction plus dure que ça ça
ça me paraissait ça me
paraissait autour de cela vous savez je
crois qu'il y a certaines personnes qui
ont des carts de presse autour de de ce
plateau ou encore qui en ont eu autour
de cette
de presse non mais je suis pas en train
de dire que je suis en train de dire je
regarde pas tous les invités un à un en
sachant le CV parfaitement ouais ce que
je suis en train de dire c'est que vous
regardez que la FP a été sommé de
s'expliquer au Sénat sur sa position
éditoriale h et ça je j'ai pas entendu
beaucoup de gens son fusquer par rapport
à ça c'estàd qu'on dit non mais écoutez
non non mais c'est très bien moi je dis
aujourd'hui la FP la FP ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est uneadmissible mais la
FP FP n'a plus aucune crédibilité depuis
très vous save g
Fr mais l'agence France press pour moi
ça fait des années que moi ça n pas
valeurcoup sa c'est parce qu'on a une
carte de PR qu'on un bon
journaliste des to de PR Mo j'en pas par
exemple
voilà j'aime beauuccoup la FP je trouve
absolument scandaleux
écouteavoc on je vais leur dire voilà PL
téléone pas de difficulté ce que je
trouve gra dans un P je pense que vous
VZ mieux que ça non moi j'aime beaucoup
les journalistes et la liberté de la
presse oh bah vous savez moi j'aime
beaucoup ça et ben vous avez bien
raison vous savez les journalistes
parfois c'est comme dans tous les
métiers comme des avocats et les très
bons avocats très mavais avocats
journalist par moi je vais vous dire la
liberté de la presse pour moi c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
que l'on puisse Sommer à des
journalistes à un PDG oui il est allé
s'expliquer au Sénat lui indiquer vous
non lité
de mais c'est normal parce que tous les
patrons je vous explique juste point
c'est un point très simple tous les
patrons de presse tous les patrons de
presse et notamment ceux qui du public
doivent venir s'expliquer très
régulièrement devant la
commission cultur mais bien sûr que ce
soit delphinnot que ce soit le patron de
la FP que ce soit le patron de France
madame saragos sur
les on leur a reproché la position
éditoriale vous trouvez que c'est quel
chose norm vous avez
drit journal par que êt
ventp c'est vraiment il do juste donner
l' combien de fois j'ai des articles sur
moi qui était aussi où la FP ne donnait
pas l'info il prenait
partie c'est un autre exemple donc lap
lap doiv être ils doivent juste donner
une inf on leur demande pas on leur
demande pas de d'avoir voilà d'avoir un
avis moi par contre par ex a des truc
sur moi exemple ils ont écrit des choses
où il donn leur avis voilà la FP n'a pas
donné son avis donner son info c'est
exactement ce qu' répondu le Président
Directeur Général en disant qu'un
réalité nen déplaise aux gens il devait
dire ce qu'il voi et voir ce qu'il
voi je vous dire la FP c'est plus que
c'était il y a 10 ans et la FP
aujourd'hui n'a plus aucune crédibilité
cétait toujours mieux avant bah oui mais
c'est toujours mieux
avant dans
journalisme ple d'amis journalistes moi
j'en ai
pas on est rassuré parce que on vous a
d'abord reprocher d'être un peu
technique et un peu froid et là on a vu
que vous avez parlé avec votre cœur et
on a vu de quel côté vous étiez c'est
quoi le côté je suis de quel côté de la
FP en tout cas de la liberté de la
presse c'est un honneur que vous me
faites de la direction de
lap il faut
êtretez la maternité de vos propos
madame vous me dites que je suis d'un
côté vous me dites que je suis d'un côté
vous me dites de la FP du côté de la
liberté de la presse je
persist
dire c'est vra que la FP ne représente
pas toute toute la liberté de la presse
je ne dis pas qu' sont indivisible des
journalistes qui sont très bien comme on
a dit des très bon
jour partout il y a des chroniqueurs
extraordinaires comme d'autes qui
sont je je vais vous dire et dans tous
les plateaux voilà et comme les avocats
vous l'avez bien rappelé ce que je dis
parce que vous êtes en train de vouloir
me faire griief en me disant et ça
c'est
endigr vous inqutez pas du tout puis que
moi je suis pas choqué par la la
décision vous êtes d'un côté je vous ai
demandé de quel côté vous m'avez dit la
FP oui je suis du côté de la liberté de
la presse nous vous en déplais liberté
de la PR tout les cas vous êtes un très
bon avocat puisque effectivement vous
avez pour le moment justement justement
je voudrais
revenir vous vous est-ce que pour vous
se moqué des horreurs du Hamas ou pas
dans la vidéo non écoutez je si votre
question c'est de dire est-ce qu'elle
regrette elle regrette que ce message
est extrêmement mal compris j'ai on peut
pas le comprendre
autrement comprend cétait limpide
ambig pas
d'interétation tout le monde comprend
l'ironie c'est très très simple à
comprendre quand on décrit un plat avec
des bébés et
comment binaire ququ
coniss pasination
laissez le parler
allez-y allez-y pas vousut-êre le cadre
de la
véritéiss c'est très bien alors ce que
je suis en train de vous expliquer c'est
qu'il y a des règles en droit d'accord
ok donc en fait si vous voulez dans
cette audience il a été notamment
débattu de l'idée de savoir est-ce que
cette information était vérifiée
vérifiable et si elle était oui ou non
une fausse nouvelle ça a été ça la
question et donc pour faire l'apologie
du terrorisme la question juridique qui
s'est posée peut-on faire l'apologie de
quelque chose qui n'est pas avéré c'est
ça la question qui s'est posée dans la
salle d'audience maintenant vous pouvez
vous surexciter si vous le souhaitez non
mais je dis je dis pas non mais non mais
attendez s'il vous plaît je peux pas je
suis pas
3 ce que je suis en train de vous
expliquer c'est que vous pouvez
expliquer si vous souhaitez que
moralement vous trouver ça inadmissible
il y a pas il y a pas de difficulté ce
que je vous dis moi c'est que
juridiquement pour faire qu'une
infraction soit constituée il faut des
éléments voilà maintenant vous pouvez
décider est-ce que vous moralement vous
tr Vié moi j'ai pas à me
positionner j'ai pas à me positionner
mais vous avez envie de me tirer vers
votre chemin
avec Mo je pas ché je puiss vous dire
des choses que je ne veux pas vous dire
parce que je suis invité en tant
qu'avocat en tant que militant quoi en
fait ce qui aurait été très simple qui
aurait été très simple c'est qu'en fait
on montre à cette dame lui mettre 10
mois avec surcis de lui montrer les
images en fait importe peu importe qu' a
eu un four ou pas les images les images
elles sont claires c'est ça il y a plein
de personnes qui les des personnes qui
sont
r des personnes vousêtes en train de
détourner le
sujet ce que j'ai dit c'est l'idée d'une
fausse nouvelle ou pas
roit vous êtes conscient que on est vous
êtes vous êtes vous nous avez embarqué
dans un dans une espèce de débat
extrêmement juridique alors vous faites
très bien votre métier puisque vous avez
réussi à effectivement limiter la casse
non mais j'ai bien compris par ailleurs
vous n'êtes pas magistrat donc c'est pas
à vous de rendre la justice vous vous
êtes là pour défendre votre client donc
jusque là d'accord mais vous êtes
d'accord sur le fait que il y a un
problème nous on est choqué par le fond
de ce qu'elle
Ditis sur la mort d'un
enfant donner comme argument le fait que
potentiellement ce bébé ne soit pas mort
dans un four mais ça va pas ou
quoi
don soitou qu' soit pas dans la vérité
on s'en
fout je crois que vous maîtriser un peu
plus le sujet il
ma
maen quand je vous ai parlé de la fausse
nouvelle vous vous semblz acqué il y a
eu un certain nombre plidé oui non c'est
parce que j'ai plaidé c'est le
gouvernement
Isra vous l'avez vu le film vous vous
l'avez vu le film que tout le monde a vu
quel film le film qui a été diffus 45
minutes on été diff
à elle est pas jugé pour le massacre du
7 octobre monur c'est quoi le rapport en
fait c'est un très mauvais messageelle
est pris que 10 mois de prison ave sur
déjà elle est pas condamné et je suis
franchement demander so diff pour savoir
si c'est une fake news je trouve que
magistrater on n pasain de dire la fait
c'est les attentats du 7 octobre non
mais il faut atterrir
second commeéfier mon
elle était jugée pour l'apologie du
terrorisme une provocation à la haine la
provocation à la haine on a surci à
statuer parce que une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité est
déposé pour savoir si on peut juger en
droit de la presse une infraction compar
immédiate reste l'apologie du terrorisme
l'apologie du terrorisme c'est une
infraction on en déplaise encore aux
gens qui nous reprochent d'être
technicien en tant qu'avocat qui demande
des éléments constitutifs vous parlez
d'attentat terroriste du 7 octobre 2023
pour lesquels madame n'a absolument rien
à voir donc qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous essayez de susciter en mettant
d'accord Pascal
pascé maîre maître on va sortir de la
stratégie effectivement sur le sur le
fond du droit vous avez raison je vais
vous poser une autre question moi c'est
l'attitude de cette de cette jeune femme
qui m'a un peu surprise choqué qu'
choqué attendez je vais vous dire je
vais vous demander si c'est votre
stratégie parce que quand le procureur a
requis les 10 mois de prison elle s'est
fait passer pour une victime elle a dit
ma vie est devenue en enfer j'ai des
menaces de mort elle s'est fait passer
pour une victime moi j'ai été ex
est-ce que c'est votre stratégie d'avoir
fait passer cette femme qui a tenu des
propos inadmissibles pour une
victime question peux répondre
si l'avocat que je suis déjà vous pose
la question comment savez-vous qu'elle a
pas été victime de
VI on s' fout de ça me fout dem demain
demain je vais insulter des gens sur les
réseaux je vais avoir des
gars
s' fiche si one la question al
adressez-vous à votre chroniqueuse V CHR
mais oui mais pas à
moi mais attendez non mais c'est lunaire
on est en train de me faire GRI vous
monsieur Hanouna vous me faites GRI
d'une question qui vient de quelqu'un de
votre
plateau mais est-ce que cétait votre
stratégie est-ce que c'était non parce
que vous dites oui elle a été qu'est-ce
que vous en savez qu'elle été qu'elle a
pas été victime mais c'est normal sur
les
réseaux si elle avait rien fait si elle
avait rien fait elle aurait eu aucun
message négatif sur les réseaux si elle
avait rien fait vous savez écoutez elle
a indiqué certaines choses à l'audience
là je suis en train d'entendre que ce
serait une stratégie de
dire et de décrire des faits je dis que
effectivement elle a subi un harcèlement
qui est monstre et si pour vous c'est
normal que les citoyens s'emparent de
quelqu'un qui potentiellement a commis
des délits et qui a une justice
parallèle et alternative de la même
manière que moi un groupe pro israélien
sur Canal téégram me met des captures en
disant maître ilassine Malaoui la cible
il faut absolument s'occuper et cetera
ça c'est inadmissible
inadmissible
inadmissibleacteil PLA PEE attende
oncepte pas du tout vousz rien fait vous
avez juste fait votre travail mais par a
dit les choses fait non il y a un lien
avec cela c'est-à-dire que il faut
nommer les choses est-ce que l'on peut
accepter que la lièe populaire s'empare
des gens pour leur faire un procès en
amont mais c'est un fait
est-ce qu'elle sexcusé elle sexcusé ou
pas elle a dit à la barre qu'elle
regrettait que son message é mal perçu
elle
reg pe savoir son ça été mal compris
alors on est tous idiot tout le
monde vous êes je suis pas en train de
critiquer votre compréhension ou pas
atttion les
audien oui vous travaz excusez-moi
monsieur pardon c'est vrai vous avez pas
le temps
vousite mais oui vous m'invitez pour
m'assommer de référ pour m'assommer de
choses compris qu'est qu' fallait
comprendre comprendre c'est que dans une
salle d'audience on fait du
droit donc dans cette à cette audience
vous AZ parler que de droit jamais il a
été question des propos exactement du
droitd des propos en lien avec le droit
n qu'est-ce que vous pensez des propos
mais attendez non mais lui il a dit
qu'il le dira pas il le dira pas ce ce
qu'il pense des propos n n alors moi je
voulais réagir en tant que personne qui
regarde les réseaux sociaux j'y suis par
le biais de ce que je fais moi ces
propos je parle de ces propos je ne
parle pas de la salle d'audience parce
qu'on n pas au tribunal ils ont été très
choquant parce que pour moi qu'est-ce
qu'on donne aux enfants comme image
c'est-à-dire on incite des enfants à
dire des propos de dire tout et
n'importe quoi sur les réseaux et de pas
être puni de ce qu'on dit oui parce
qu'après je suis désolé il est facile de
dire des conneries sur Internet et de
dire je suis désolé je savais pas ou
j'ai pas compris parce que moi-même qui
suis
handicapé je suis pas handicapé de la
tête mais j'ai très bien compris ce
qu'elle a dit et c'était très choquant
et pour moi pour les propos qu'elle a
tenu elle mérite une sanction et tout le
monde comme il a dit Monsieur Hanouna
quand tu dis une connerie ou que tu
insultes quelqu'un tu mérites une
sanction à un moment donné il faut
arrêter on peut pas tout cautionner sur
le fait que c'est les réseaux sociaux et
qu'on a le droit de tout dire et après
revenir sur les propos et pour TER qu'
soit excusé après elle a regretté elle
s'est pas
excusé voilà mais elle a regretté en
disant a priori si je reprends vos
propos que on aurait pas compris son
message moi ce que j'aimerais savoir
c'est quoi son message que je vous
expliqu c'est pas si le message c'est
que elle elle parlait de la pour elle
c'était une fake news voilà ça mais bon
voilà pas mais bon en fait c'est que si
on regarde la presse même le journaliste
SH Levinson d' expliquer très
bien moi j'ai une question précise pour
vous votre cliente d'accord elle a
expliqué à l'audience que l'attaque du 7
octobre était terroriste mais elle a
refusé de dire que le Hamas est une an
terre je vous pose la question vousê hum
que H uneganisation TER
vantavocre
venil merci pu on espère vous
l'avocè alors moi la FP c'est moi
c'était bien avant ça j'ai jamais pu
lesplirer euh ils ont toujours mis des
trucs sur moi la FP pour moi c'est
l'agence euh France prout voilà euh je
vous le dis moi moi c'est une agence que
je respecte et s veul m' RA vous savez
bah allez travailler là-bas et puis
j'espère que j'espère que vous ferez des
procès je les gagnerai
allez